اي لقب يليق بالرحل بليه اكثر من الاسطوره
فهي تاتي مره واحده وعندها تروى ملايين
السرديات طوى النجم البرازيلي اثني 82 سنه
ورحل ليشتحق قارات العالم الخمس طوفان من
الرثاء النجم الفرنسي كيليان مبابي كتب
رحل ملك كره القدم عنا لكن ارثه لن ينسى
ابدا فلترقد بسلام يا ملك الهداف النرويجي
ايرلنج لاند كتب بدوره ان كل ما يفعله
اللاعبون حاليا كان بيليه اول من قام به
حساب فيفا المتخصص بالاحصائيات نشر ابرز
انجازات اللاعب الكرويه وعلى راسها تفرضه
بحملك كاس العالم ثلاث مرات وانه اصغر
لاعب يحمله ناهيك عن تتويجه بجائزه لاعب
القرن والكره الذهبيه من بين عديد الالقاب
ومن عالم السياسه دون الرئيس الفرنسي
باللغه بلاده وبالمبرتغاليه
هي اللاعب الملك الخلود ام الرئيس
الامريكي السابق باراك اوباما فاذهب من
قول انبيليه كان من اعظم اللاعبين الذين
لعبوا رياضه كره القدم معتبرا انه احد
اشهر رياضيين العالم لفهمه قوه الرياضه في
التقريب ما بين الناس سيره طويله للاعب
استثنائي تخطط شهته نجوم هوليود والرؤساء
دول وغير من شكل كره القدم داخل وخارج
المستطيل الاخضر والاقاء اجماعا من محبه
وخصومه الرياضيين على السواء